bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions sur arte france pourquoi cet
assouplissement des règles
malgré le conflit mais qui va donc durer
jusqu'au 3 mai un gros bémol d'abord
pour dire que cet assouplissement il
devra être considérés sur le terrain
pour voir s'il existe vraiment parce que
depuis le début du confinement ce qu'on
appelle le lock down
il ya énormément de directives des du
gouvernement fédéral ou bien des états
provinciaux pour assouplir faciliter la
circulation notamment en matière de
circulation des produits agricoles les
moissons qui doivent battre son plein le
transport etc
et rien n'y fit vie des faits dans
beaucoup de régions
cela dit c'est sûr que c'est ces règles
si elles sont assouplies vont dans un
sens politiquement tout à fait
souhaitable 1 étant donné que la
situation des plus pauvres est
absolument catastrophique en inde qu'on
meurt de faim on meurt de différentes
maladies bien plus qu'on ne meurt du
coronavirus pour l'instant et donc ne
serait ce que pour assurer la sécurité
alimentaire du pays pour que ces
moissons et lieu vraiment pour que les
agriculteurs ne se suicide pas trop il
faut à un moment ou un autre
relâché un petit peu le fait chaque qui
est sûr le pays
justement vous dites en meurent d'autres
choses plus que du vide 19 en inde selon
l'université john hopkins il y aurait à
2400 cas en inde pour 420 morts un pays
qui compte on le rappelle un milliard
trois cents millions d'habitants est ce
que ces chiffres ne sont pas
sous-évaluer est ce qu'on connaît la
dimension réelle
l'épidémie en inde non bien sûr à
personne ne me connaît et donc tout le
monde peut à juste titre penser que ces
chiffres sont sous-évaluées mais même si
vous vouliez multiplié par cinq par dix
voire même par 100 c'est tout à fait
faible à l'échelle comme vous l'avez dit
de 1 4 milliard d'habitants n'oubliez
pas que de la tuberculose meurent chaque
jour mille personnes en gros mille
personnes donc vous voyez que c'est à
rapprocher de ses de ses 420 morts à peu
près depuis le début de la crise
officiellement lié encore une à virus
mais justement on sait qu'il ya donc des
pathologies qui sont tus en présentant
en inde le fait d'avoir par dessus le
coronavirus ce qui peut pas y avoir une
catastrophe sanitaire même j'ai envie de
dire humanitaire en inde avec cette
pandémie
oui en fait je pense que l'inde suit le
le remède france est un
c'est à dire que comme la france mais
dans une situation encore pire
on manque de test on manque de masque on
manque de lits d'hôpital
donc tout est fait pour essayer de
d'aplatir cette fameuse courbe d arrivée
à l'hôpital
sauf qu'on a on n'a pas du tout les
moyens de la france qui souffre pourtant
donc vous pouvez imaginer la situation
ici est ce qui apparaît c'est que étant
donné que l'accent est mis sur le cobra
navires us énormément d'autres maladies
qui doivent être traités ne le sont plus
correctement parce qu'on manque de
médicaments parce qu'on manque de
médecins parce que certaines petites
cliniques rurales sont fermées les
écoles étant fermées bien les cantines
qui offrent le repas de gratuit le repas
de midi gratuit à tout le monde
ne fonctionne plus etc etc donc il ya
énormément de conséquence indirecte du
virus qui sont pour l'instant en tout
cas bien plus grave que le virus
lui-même et comment les indiens juge la
gestion de crise du gouvernement de
narindra maudit quelles sont les aides
prévues par par new delhi pour pour
aider les les indiens qui sont les plus
démunis par exemple oui alors il ya des
aides qui sont fournis par le
gouvernement fédéral le programme tel
qu'il a été donnée concerne 1 % du pib
donc ce sont des sommes très faibles a
pour pour à mettre en regard d'ailleurs
des dépenses de santé qui sont aussi
très faible de l'ordre de 1 1%
donc on est vraiment en fonction des
besoins je pense très en deçà de des
besoins à côté de ça il faut ajouter
quand même ce que font les états
provinciaux et n'oubliez pas qu'il ya 28
états provinciaux on est un peu comme
l'europe et donc chaque état à ses
marges de manoeuvre
ils ont leurs cantines publiques ils ont
des distributions de vivres ils ont des
systèmes comme on voir là sur les images
de d'arrosage de désinfectant plus ou
moins plus ou moins bienvenu et puis
aussi à des initiatives individuelles
d'associations de city jones comme on
dit un de deux personnes relativement
aisée mais qui vont essayer de
distribuer des vivres mais souvent ils
se font bastonner par la police parce
que au nom de l'interdiction de
rassemblement au nom de la distance de
sécurité
eh bien on interdit parfois c'est
distribution de riz de galettes de blés
façon à mon avis c'est à considérer
merci frédéric l'envié d'avoir a répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur de l'institut français
à pondicherry